okay here we go ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to your absolutely
favorite podcast you know the name
okay spencer let's go this is how we do
it i always hand the singing mic over to
the guest
and whatever you got this is it griffin
[Music]
okay hey and i'm before you're gripping
and i'm singing the blues
and i'm sitting here in my most comfy
shoes
yeah if you don't like it i'm gonna give
you
booze
[Music]
cause with the whip griffin that shit's
the truth
yeah yeah i love it it's a freestyle
singing
that was awesome
[Music]
all right anyway yeah that was great i
knew you would be great on that
what's up guys this is eric griffin i
want to talk about green chef one of the
most sustainable meal kits out there on
the market
try green chef today the number one meal
kit
for eating well go to
greenchef.comgriffin100
and use code griffin100 to get
100 off including free shipping
that's green chef man i didn't know that
you could you could sing sing until you
did that little duet oh
i know and i'll have to show that right
now the boom
just a small town girl
living in a lonely world
she took the midnight train going
anywhere
[Music]
you're just really great you know what i
mean like you got a real good you got
like a soulful
and what song was that like oh it was a
journey yeah yeah
but but i love how you do it like you
take like because you obviously do the
instrumental and stuff yourself
yeah yeah right then that's how you
don't get dinged yeah it's
it's all just like i just record
acoustic guitar and then uh and then
just
sing over it yeah it's great man that's
easy i mean it's great and that's a good
i mean
did you get um were you doing that
before doing like you know
covers and youtube stuff before to like
you know get some notoriety and stuff
like that
that's definitely what i started doing
like you know six years ago before i
even moved here like yeah
yeah i was doing youtube covers and not
really gaining any traction on youtube
about it
i kind of missed that cover thing that
2015 thing i missed it that's like me
and my dvds i still have to sell
yeah we're holding under that aladdin uh
special edition
no no no i have like i'm talking about
my special dvd which you can get on my
website if you're still in the dvds but
like i got a bunch of them
right when it was like nobody's doing
that anymore but that's coming but it
might be coming back around and then
you'll be
all right i'll be on i'll be first to do
it yeah then i'll be like retro but you
know what before you answer that
question and keep going i forgot to even
do this ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the podcast my good friend longtime
friend
mr spencer sutherland uh
fantastic singer actor too actor singer
songwriter and he's here so anyways
yeah so you so you do the you did the
acoustic of uh and then
if you look at my instagram on a real he
did a reel then i did like a duet
reel with his reel yeah i mean i'm
nowhere near what what you're you're
doing you have that little
you know you have a little soulfulness
in your uh yeah i heard you do that yeah
yeah that's my everybody loves my
woo-woos i haven't had woo-woo shirts
get the merch on air griffin
store merch yeah i'm gonna have to
visit the site right after this so uh
yeah but i know what you mean there was
like a big trend where it was like
everybody was singing covers
yeah it was it was definitely this thing
and that's like that's how i started but
it never really
did much and then it was it was just
really when tick tock came back
i've been doing original music right for
five years or whatever and um
and tick tock came back and it was just
like i think i
you know i i i just sang like uh you
know that song by the four non-blondes
uh in the wick and the morning in a step
outside yeah so i did that and it went
crazy viral and i was like
oh [__] new fan like new people because
you can't tour during the last year
so i'm like oh [__] this is the way i
can get new people and then i just
started singing
i fell into this like niche of like is
it niche or niche
i think it's like tomato tomato i fell
into this
all right we'll start the new trend it's
like
there's a gnosh that i'm doing i started
doing like elton john and queen
and like journey and stuff and then you
got that vibe anyway you're like the
high pants master dude i wore these
pants for you
yeah this guy's like with his high pants
you always got like
halter top jeans on um yeah you say
you always comment uh high voice evil
higher pants yeah it's ridiculous but
so then all right bring it back man so
you started doing all that stuff but you
got your own vibe you're like you know
it's like
um you know i guess that's like a all
part of it you know i talked about this
on my podcast before when i
do you watch american idol yeah i grew
up watching it i love american idol and
i really i would love to see you on
american idol i um got american house
story for you later
oh i'd love that to do that but so one
thing okay so this i don't know if you
watched this past season but the
the big kid uh what's his name um willie
williams willie yeah you know willie
that dude can't [__] sing man can
like
like i was blown away every time to
tears i was
i must have cried like three times
watching willie with his story and
everything
it's like that level of singing where
like he probably hasn't even taken vocal
lessons like
he's he was born with that thing and the
thing the like layers of his voice you
hear
are like you know the past 20 years of
his life like growing up like
where he's been what he's doing well i
think he does i think he was in a choir
and he does like you know right you know
all that stuff but my point is
because i want to ask you about this so
there was that one uh when it was um
coldplay was there mm-hmm you know and
uh he was the mentor the guy was a
mentor gotcha you know what i mean chris
martin chris
he's the mentor and he so then willie
sung their song um
uh yellow you know and the way he sung
it i was like
god damn but then i thought to myself
the guy in coldplay can't sing like this
guy yeah but he could write a song
and i thought to myself what to so my
question to you is
what makes the artist is it the
instrument
that you know the voice like you take
willy who
the guy sings beautifully but then when
you combine that with
a song like yellow yeah like so so then
when you start to go well then where
really is the art
or if you had like a sliding a slider
where would you put it more would you
put it more over on the crisps on the
coldplay or would you put them more over
on willy and what do you think about
that
well that's dude that's so like that's
like an amazing question because it's
it's both answers sometimes there's an
artist
like passenger the only need to lie
when you let it go who can't really sing
that well but his
songwriting is [__] wild and then
there's people like
um ariana unbelievable vocalist
i don't even think i i don't even know
if she's like a bad writer i just i
don't know what she's written on but
like she's not known for like
writing and then you hit the magic
pocket right in the middle where you get
bruno mars and adele who can write
the perfect song and also have the best
voice in the world
but but i think i think that's a magical
thing about music is some people are
really drawn to like vocals and and
performances some people are like all
about songwriting
but see i would say to you i would
challenge that to say that
i think people don't really know what
they're drawn to because they're not
aware
and i and and so so when i'm watching
that american auto episode i thought it
was a great example
to make yourself aware because i
listened to
like i went to like uh spotify or
whatever and i looked up willy he's got
original songs
they're not very good see that you know
that's they're not very good so then
so what i'm saying is so here's a guy
and you go even if they're a great
singer
and you hear a song that you don't
really like or if a song is like so what
i'm saying is
does singing itself make something good
or real or is it the um what do you call
it the arrangement
and the songwriting and and whatever
goes behind that that really
that completes it that is crazy because
you're right it's like in a a thing like
that it's right in front of your face
it's like here is a person who's an um
one of the best singers right
around yeah here's one of the best songs
ever
thank you and uh and it's like putting
in front of your face so you can't
really ignore it
um and it's kind of easy to see that way
but
man if bruno mars sings a mcdonald's
theme song to the best of his talents
i'm maybe gonna cry you know i you know
i
maybe man i don't know i mean because
i'm starting to coming from a vocalist
though
got you so you're technically you're
going to be like that person can't
really see bias as hell already i
write all my own music but and i love i
love lyrical stuff like
you know i think john mayer is one of
the best songwriters in the world and
i love his lyrics but but i think i'm
drawn to vocals first
uh-huh well there's an example of a guy
that so so let's uh if you were putting
an equation together of like what
you know an artist a performer
yeah so then you would have image then
you would have
songwriting uh and we'll put songwriting
and arrangement and all that in that
yeah not just and then you have the
actual vocal instrument
okay and so two out of three ain't bad
obviously
yeah three out of three is a superstar
though two out of three is the
superstructure
those are those that are rare the rare
breeds of people that you know you have
or or even or even if like even if you
have like you say a hundred percent
then you go it's like you know it'll be
like
70 image you know what i'm saying
you know 20 this 10 percent the other so
it's even it's not even like it's all
even in that case because then you got
somebody like justin bieber
who i think has the image part
yeah like the image and whatever that is
that goes with the physical and all that
that part is super high for him you know
yeah
and i think i think is it i think the
cool thing about someone like him is
his equation probably shifts a little
bit over time like now his music kind of
like
yes let's add 10 to the music pot let's
take away five percent from the i mean
he's look he looks great he looks cool
yeah he's always gonna let so i'm saying
that's always gonna be a high percentage
yeah but i feel like that sometimes it's
like you know because he writes some of
his own music too you know what i mean
he's a musician he's been since he was
nine years old but what i'm saying is
there's one of those things where you go
okay this is a good combination
i would say the thing that he lacks the
most in would be vocals and they're
still pretty good
i'm saying in comparison to the music
and the image and then the vocals i mean
there's always going to be a thing that
you know that you're out of girth that
you're missing you know
and so you know you get a guy like a
person like john mayer or a lot of these
like good
white boy guitar artists you know what i
mean lots of them
there that is a factor you know like i
was
i i didn't think the guy that one
american auto should have won
between those three voc you're talking
about a singing competition you're
talking about vocalists that check grace
and willie like they stay the way they
sing
but then you go all right but this
equation is not
full because then because this is a
great example like willy versus chase is
a great example of where
because willie's image that's not where
you would put
no you wouldn't put his percentage of
that is probably super low to people you
know
but it's chase's name yeah the winner
yeah but he's got that
image down but he's got more of like an
even across the keel when you talk about
for sure
songwriting it's like nothing is
standing out but the equation is there
so i mean i don't know i just think like
our equation theory is
that's i've never heard it put like that
that's a really great way to put it i
just feel like it's dead-on right
because even
because even with yourself when i you're
a great vocalist okay you are you're a
great singer man thank you
you're a great singer you got a good
image you got your own style you know
you get your high-waisted style
and you know and all that you're very
retro you're like the bell-bottoms type
guy you're the kind of guy to have on
big sunglasses like elsa john
i get your style so that's great uh but
the thing is like when i hear you sing
like a song that i know the song and
that's the beauty
of american idol you know it's like you
go oh man that guy is great
yeah but what i'm starting that's one
well ask is is go is to go like so then
where do would you think you're lacking
in
um or where would you want your not
lacking that's not the right
i don't mean it like that no that's i
mean that's actually like a real like
where's
your what's your question percentage
yeah um
you know what's funny is i i i finally
felt like i found like this
style i guess of clothing and aesthetic
whatever you want to call it
aesthetic that's a good word yeah
aesthetics is important it's an image
business
yeah it's just it's what i truly like i
used to kind of try to even when i first
met you i
had the i had the the dumbass um like
fade faux hawk hair oh yeah you had your
you had your white boy's woof
i had the white boy i i did i really did
uh you got a [__] we got a show you got
to send me a picture i think a picture
of like
when you first just me clenching my jaw
looking at the camera probably somewhere
uh and and then like you know i tried to
be like every other
white boy long t-shirt pop person and
then when it wasn't working and nobody
wanted to see that industry and fans
alike i was like what do i i'd
really really you know reach inside and
i was like what do i what do i like i
like elvis i like
i like you know jimi hendrix i like
elton john i like queen
like that's what i that's what i truly
love
so i kind of just started you know just
wearing whatever the [__] i wanted and
and
it just changed up everything that was
the biggest the biggest change because
before that i would put my
my image at a zero got you i don't know
if it was a zero but it was bomber jack
it's almost like a two
yeah so but i mean i think that you were
uh it was
so when the how about this when the
image
is low when that part of the equation is
low
a lot of times it could be low because
it's not original
because i didn't know who i was here
right right right right yeah a hundred
percent
that that's that's that's exactly what
it was i had no idea who i was and i was
just trying to be like
name the white boy pop artist got you um
and then when i figured it out it all
just
fell naturally um i i think
i i think i can i can hold my own
against any vocalist
um you know what before you even
continue i can tell because how we're
talking about this and as you're like
embracing this idea of this like
equation that we've come up with like
this
yeah but i could tell like it's hard to
talk about for you i could i could feel
a little uncomfortableness if you like
because it's like
because it's like a self-reflecting
right now it's kind of like well damn am
i
am i not doing this enough am i not
doing it's like we're making this thing
because even in my business i could
think about it too i could think about
it's like image material okay it's the
same thing in commute comedy
image material and then performance
those things go into a play of like you
know you know and i can think about even
for myself
right like what's your what's your
strong suit yeah yeah so i already know
for me
image is not going to be the biggest one
for me i'm just i'm just not like a you
know i'm not a
you know what i mean i'm not like a
looker like that you know i'm
funny-looking
you know what i mean man you know what
i'm saying thank you but you know what
the [__] i mean
you know so then i go then i would say
sometimes for me it's like my strongest
suit is my performance
yeah i'm a big performer on stage but
then i would say then
what is lacking for me what i want to be
better is my material
what i talk about how i talk about it i
got that down
i know how to make something funny but
how what i'm talking about is the thing
that
sets people apart you know when you take
somebody that's got like you know like
dave chappelle
you know he's a generally good looking
guy you know he's a manly man type guy
on stage he's got a great material
and he has great performance yeah he
does and that's why
he's like one of the best he's somebody
like kevin hart same kind of thing you
know
he's a good looking dude in shape
whatever you know he's got
you know i would say for him his good
looking guy
and his performance those are his
strengths and then
the material isn't his strongest one but
it's still hot it's a good enough
percentage
right i think when when you when uh just
a person like like when i think about
this
i'm thinking oh [__] like my lowest
thing means that it sucks
doesn't mean that at all right and when
you said that i was like oh yeah that's
right so i would say my original music i
stand by it 100
i think it's [__] amazing and you
know especially the stuff that's not
even out yet but
but i i i think i could i could even
just be
realer you know what i mean you know you
don't even you know it's it's a weird
conversation to have and i totally
understand
the apprehension about i totally
understand like because it's like it
makes me even go for myself when i think
about it go
oh it's like right but it doesn't mean
it's bad it doesn't mean it's bad but
it's like it's still the thing is like
you want to be better and at the same
time too it's like you want
you want to know it's better because of
the reaction you're getting from
you know friends and fans yeah so it's
like yes it's like first of all let's
just be
100 about this it's hard to write a
great song
yeah it's really it's really if it was
easy to write a great song everybody
would be doing it
now there is like um you know
aesthetically pleasing to the ear type
songs that does you know so you have the
bubble gum pop and you have like you
know
uh there's a certain you know chord
progression that you know you know what
i mean
yeah i'm sure as an artist you know what
i'm talking about it's like you hear
avila lovreen song and you go oh man she
uses that same chord progression
every maroon five song eight of her
songs right maroon five there's all
these people you go oh this is great and
he there's a guy who's got the great
vocal
you know he's got that distinct vocal
presence even if it's not
even if he's not the greatest singer
textbook good
it's still you know what's adam lovely
yeah
yeah right exactly it's original it's
like so he's got a great equation that's
worked
so you're trying to figure out your
equation right now and i totally get
that but it's like you know
yeah i remember hearing a story about
kelly clarkson you know like so she know
she
she had great songwriters you know
whoever the songwriters were that got
her going and then like
yeah there was that one album where she
was like i want to do this on my own and
the head of the thing was like
i don't think you should do this i think
you should let us write these songs for
you
so you can you know be a hit and of
course she put out an album that was
just
not good yeah every every big artist
does that justin timberlake man of the
woods every artist does that thing and
they're like
oh yeah that's right yeah i forgot the
thing that but i don't mind
somebody going like well i don't want to
do this anymore that's cool
i want to move on to like to try
something new but what i'm saying is
don't be mad if the people are like we
don't like it
yeah you got you got it you gotta you
know if you're gonna go
for it you gotta be prepared for for you
know you're not doing the same [__]
for the last 10 years that you've been
doing so you got to prepare for like
different opinions now do you feel like
you're going for it i mean do you feel
like that um
like did you that you've made your best
work do you feel like
you know oh man these songs like where
are you in the in in your process
i i the last couple of years have been
so exciting because
like i was just talking about i found my
image and my sound right so
i i the stuff i've been putting out i
feel like has just been sort of like
getting better and better and better and
the stuff that i'm about to put out
is um is the best
[__] that i've ever written it's really
i'm really excited about it that's good
man and i'm singing saying
i'm not just kind of saying when i'm
going for it you ain't singing you sang
him i'm saying that's actually how i
describe i'm like oh no you're singing
he's saying that's an artist that i uh
but i set myself up for failure
not failure just like i write songs so
difficult to sing so that when i perform
live after the song i'm like shh why'd i
do that i have a whole i have a i have a
song called sweater and the entire
chorus is
really high falsetto and it's great but
on stage it's high as hell now do you
think do you do that on purpose then are
you
do you find yourself like you like like
like are you
actively being like i want to set myself
apart i want to show you people i can
sing
for sure for sure i just kind of like
i mean in writing and vocal stuff yeah
like some like
that the sweater song is that's my
sweater why the [__] you got it on and
it's just all falsetto
and uh and i think i like that so much
is because i've never
heard that in my life or anything like
that i'll all stem from a spongebob
cartoon the stripes
striped sweater episode that's a great
episode
obviously it inspired a whole song yeah
yeah
um you were saying you were saying
something about artists no i was just
thinking about like you know
something way older than you so it's
like i've like when i think about an
artist evolving
um i think about like mariah carey is a
good example
so like i remember so i was around when
mariah carey first
started i was in high school and then it
was vision of love and she had this
great album she was this vocalist she
was like competing with
uh with whitney houston it was like that
was the thing you were going like you
know and she had like so
so then like but then there's like a new
age of people who
know her as like a hip-hop person like
she just
you know all of a sudden it just like
her whole style changed and it was like
you know but then there was like but i
gotta say man i don't know if you like
you know there's a d
she has this album emancipation of mimi
mm-hmm that that's the album she was
singing on that one she was like we
coming
we coming to do some work on this album
but then there's like so many
like you know you can see you can look
at her and see an artist that has gone
through
so many different evolutions of like who
she is and what she is and
you know the best artists do that though
you know like the best artists
are are all these different kind of
things and try different stuff but yet
still stay in the same universe in a way
yeah i know but it's like
sometimes i what do you think what do
you feel about like you know
you know can an artist age gracefully
because sometimes i feel like they can't
i sometimes feel like
artists are like professional athletes
oh oh [__] yeah yeah i know you mean you
know what i mean so you have like look
at example you have somebody like
madonna
you know madonna's been like relevant
for like five decades
crazy i mean relevant yeah you know what
i mean like she like you go to her
but at the same time though it's like
you know we know her from what she did
you know she was 20 30 years old you
know doing like a virgin and singing and
dancing like that
yeah now you're talking about now it's
uh you know 70 year old madonna
you know and she's you know you ain't
like a virgin no more yeah
so like you know so sometimes i feel
like a person like that doesn't evolve
you or you get to a point where you hey
it's time to retire from
not performing but maybe
you're you're not like that anymore like
so i mean do you subscribe to that or do
you feel like you know
i kind of feel yeah i think i think um
it's definitely
more difficult for women i think for
sure you know just like
you know just aging gracefully in
general but especially in music
um yeah their equation goes like real
quick right
oh she's 35 yeah you know which is not
fair but you know
the you know i don't subscribe to it too
much because i see
i see um you know lead singers and band
like i think your performance changes
once you're like
like elton john isn't performing the
same as he did right so i think like
that's
the cool thing about you can keep
touring it's just going to be a little
bit different
yeah you can't i mean it's going to go
from elton john to like
an evening with elton john yeah it's
it's his farewell to her
yeah it's him sitting on a piano
maybe it's on a lazy susan it's going
real slow like this
and he's just playing his piano i mean i
can see you know i mean no knock i mean
there's a there's a little bit of ageism
in in the entertainment business
yeah there's definitely maybe there's a
lot of it you know what i mean but at
the same time you have
you know you have 36 year old dudes
playing high school students still so
i know but don't even get me started
it's so funny then you also have someone
like j.lo you know whose equation
clearly isn't like so because she looks
but even in her but see here she's
someone that like breaks her equation
even more sometimes because you go
you're talking about the artistry of it
too like you know so
someone that can sing and dance you know
someone you know singing
even though she's not the best singer
yeah i wouldn't consider her a vocalist
no i don't think she's ever really been
known as like vocal queen right but it's
like but the package she has put
together is like
you know boom yeah you know it's pretty
mind-blowing i mean if i think about
artists in history if i go like here's
someone that had
like it could if you could have a
hundred percent in every category so i
think of it like nba
like an nba game and they had the slider
you know that's like 100 you know
right right like if you get the cheats
you put them all up yeah yeah yeah i
think
people who's had them all up i mean i
would say someone like michael jackson
had him all up you know
you know it's like you're talking about
the image uh songwriting
performance he's singing or dancing
and a vocalist too yeah you know so this
is just been very but
then you go well that's why he was like
one of the most successful
popular artists of all time yeah i mean
that's why yeah
you know but i think everybody has
theirs everybody you're right everybody
has their own but
um who is it for you is what i'm saying
who's somebody you look back and go oh
man this person had
every single category was high and this
is why they're this
well my all-time favorite is elvis but
elvis
i only wrote probably like 20 of his
songs like he wasn't a big songwriter
but as far as performance charisma
vocals like a hundred percent i think
the one that sticks out to me though is
bruno mars
really you think bruno mars is going to
be on the level of that yeah 100
and it's you really like bruno mars
you've mentioned them a few times i do i
love bruno mars but i also think that
like there's no one who can sing like
him
there's no one i mean he's written all
your favorite songs from other artists
ceelo greene adele
um oh i didn't even know that travis
mccoy just all these different
all these different records he was a
writer and producer before and so he
he's a master songwriter master singer
the best she's missy elliott yeah right
right um you ever seen that miss
elliott clip where she she goes on the
ellen show there's like that old white
lady that raps missy elliott and then
she surprises her on stage oh no i
haven't seen this good man
it's funny the the lady like freaks out
it's really good
uh but i yeah i just put him up there
because that's like all right everything
is checked
image 100 vocals 100 writing 100 songs
100.
oh okay i wouldn't even give it 99 well
you know what you know and it's funny
because we're talking about people who
are like i really like bruno mars too i
mean i think i think it's great i mean i
just go to a show and then
and then i think you'll even get it more
because it's like oh yeah there are
people that you see them live
what do they just look at yeah you see
them live when you go whoa and i think
those are like subcategories of things
too like how are they live
yeah what's going on in concert you know
that's because that's a whole other
thing too you see
you know i saw what's that i saw a great
documentary i saw a great on netflix
um oh god what why am i forgetting his
name
you know the white guys dating the
camilla oh shawn mendes shawn
wonder and wonder yeah i saw that um
documentary and i was like oh that it
was pretty good and i felt like
i felt like that guy's got like he's on
the rise of like what what he's doing
he's writing his songs he's a great
performer he's a good looking kid
you know i mean do you do you look at
someone like that and be like oh i want
to be like that or do you
are you like you compare yourself to
people like that or do you not want to
do that but you still find yourself
doing it well i'm
like i'm constantly compared to either
shawn mendes or harry styles because
well you've got harry's hair i'm i'm
just a white guy with curly brown hair
right right
we're all around the same age so like
yeah naturally it's going to happen
but um but i mean of course like i'm i'm
never mad when i get compared
to people like that because they're dope
like it's not like i'm being compared to
a tick tocker who can't sing
who is you know losing a trailer boxing
match
or whatever um i almost bought the i
almost bought the tick tocker youtuber
fight i almost stooped down
it was gonna be horrible so i did but i
didn't uh but yeah i don't mind being
compared to people like that and like
obviously i'd love to have half of shawn
mendes he's huge
he's massive he's playing we know how
huge he was because arenas yeah i didn't
know that i did crazy that's when i saw
that i was like wow this is pretty
amazing
i even thought the ariana grande
documentary because this is doing
pandemics you just watch this stuff and
then my girl she's just like you know
you get to that place where like during
the pandemic where you
you don't question it you don't even
watch a trailer you're just like yeah
man that's where i was i was like you
know
and then it was when i was watching both
of those i thought to myself man is it
gonna are we gonna get back to that
at that particular time i was like will
we see arenas like that again
oh this is probably like right in the
the depth of the pandemic what you're
thinking this right
yeah it was a it was a weird time it was
it was
everything seemed to bleak at that point
you know what i was thinking about right
now as we're talking about this
thank goodness the clippers didn't make
the championship
because if the clippers had made the
championship and they're now doing this
indoor mask nonsense you know what i
mean
like so then wow imagine like what would
they have done would they have been like
well you can't have fans at the finals
what an unfair advantage for the other
team who like
you know if it was milwaukee who's like
well we're fine with it and you know it
would have been like a whole thing oh my
god that would have been
so weird actually right you know what
i'm saying like well we're from
milwaukee so
you don't know what i'm saying people in
milwaukee when when when the game is in
milwaukee
oh i see yourself you know what i mean
yeah it'll be like you know they're full
fans everybody's yelling and screaming
but in l.a you know they got the map
everyone's like
seven people everybody or they would
have said you can't have full i don't
even know what
what they would have done it would have
uh i don't know man i don't i don't
think it's gonna be a thing that uh
that lasts too long well especially you
know we were talking when you first came
in
it's like you know i don't think it's
like with for the sheriff to come out
and be like listen we're not enforcing
right it's the it's so funny that he's
the first person who's just like
look man this isn't science back this
isn't a cdc decision this is
we're not going to enforce this yeah
this is just it's a bad sign
for the california government yeah dude
when yeah
when the law enforcement people are like
okay good luck with that but
i don't like that by the way though i
think that's that's not good
for leadership i i agree and a guy
should be fired
even if i agree with him i a hundred
percent
agree with you okay you cannot do that
because now because you know what's
gonna do
it's gonna put it on us now you're gonna
see a lot of dust ups at places
it's gonna suck you know what i mean
because you're gonna go in and be like
well they're not enforcing this so
there's gonna be some people who are
gonna be like i'm not wearing this
they're not even enforcing it
then those people are gonna be like well
to come in here and then that's
gonna cause like this friction and
they're gonna say we'll call the cops
and they're gonna be like i will and
they'll be like sorry they won't come
and it's
yeah it's going to be a whole thing it's
going to be a whole thing and i i don't
and i think that's
not that's not good further separations
yeah not good
you know you have to have a chain of
command and the chain of command is like
in the military you know
it's like you know you have the the the
person in charge and you have that
sergeant
who's supposed to like relay those
orders you can't have the sergeant going
are you sure
you don't do that in front of the men
yeah you don't do that in front of the
man because then they start to doubt the
leadership
you take your later you go hey sir i
don't know if i agree with that
privately yeah you go you go to the he
should have went to the government been
like hey
this is my problem yeah what are you
doing man i'm not gonna you know you're
making
then they should have hashed it out
behind closed doors for him to do that
publicly like that and say that i think
that was a
that was terrible and he should be fired
for that yeah
if i was the governor that guy be gone
if i was in charge of his job like you
fired
you know but then that's a bad thing too
because then it looks like you know
that's why i'm saying he put everybody
in a bad position doing that
that's why i think it's yeah and i mean
i agree with you i
i for me and i think and everybody that
i've talked to
about this indoor mass decision
feels the same way it's it's you know
i've been vaccinated for
months right and people are getting it
though
well i know but like with vaccines it's
crazy they the promise is
you know get a vaccine you're good to go
so i get a vaccine a month later i'm not
good to go anymore they change
they changed the vibe yeah i know it's
well i mean because you're talking about
it's like not everybody wants to get
vaccinated and then like right you can't
yeah i want to you know
say but then but the thing i don't
understand is like they're going okay
you have to be indoors
and they're punished when you're indoors
you have to wear a mask but they're not
but
there's no social distancing or like
what are we saying and then you can and
then you can sit
you can wear a mask to your table but
then when you get to your table i don't
know if you knew this but
uh you can't get covered when you're
sitting that's what's happening in a
restaurant yeah yeah
it's unbelievable this feels like a dog
and pony show but
i don't know i just think we're so
really what we're talking about right
now
is like the fatigue of it all like we're
just tired of
all of this and so even if the science
is right or wrong or even if it's
we're just kind of like oh man we're
still doing this
it's like it's like it's like you gave
me a little bit then you just took it
away
and we were just starting to feel like
everything's back to normal we're going
we're going we're going and then all of
a sudden they're like well
actually i think that you know we're
gonna do this and i and i wonder like
who's that for like who are they doing
it for
it'd be one thing if biden if the
president of the united states was like
hey
you know this is a nationwide thing
we're not leaving it up to the states
you have to do this now because we are
feeling this we really want to fight
this thing
it's different when it's like it's just
california
it's not even just california it's just
l.a just l.a county it's like what
my friend from uh from ventura text me
he's just text me haha and i was like
what
he goes have fun with that and he sent
me the link and i was just like oh no
you got me going like like like my girl
and i went to orange county
uh yesterday to go to the chiropractor
and it's like orange county's not doing
that so i found myself going okay
yeah let's go to orange county yeah to
go to dinner and stuff let's make a
little
trip of it because it's like okay l.a
county you do your nonsense you know
what i mean that's like but it's like
and even if they're correct it feels
like nonsense because you're like well
how can one place do this and the other
places don't
who's right and that's the thing that's
all makes it all just
the thing yeah the thing that jumbles it
for me is how can one county out of
tens of thousands be the only one yeah
like you know what i mean like it'd be
one thing if new york and chicago
tampa and nowhere in florida but you
know all these places
like and i'm sure like all these like
faux scientists are like going off in
the comments right now they're so
you know the people they you know your
opinions of the coup is like
man you're you don't know what you're
talking about okay it's never a sign
it's never a scientist in the comments
yeah it's never somebody who's like i
work with this and let me
give you because because a smart person
would give you facts they're not going
to attack you like a [__] troll you
know what i mean oh man
you know so like i know you're in you're
mid writing right now i don't care
just like oh yeah yes you know so i
don't know
that's not even this yeah we're we're
armchair scientists
i'm not even trying to be a scientist
i'm just trying to be like make it make
sense for me that's all
i think make it make sense for quite
literally [__] anybody yeah just make
it make sure that makes sense
because you just go you know you just
your common sense is making you go
wait what what what yeah yeah so like so
like uh i'm driving to ventura and as
soon as we hit the border i can take my
mask off and it's okay over here or like
you know
or the rule tonight like at 11 59
you can never mask off but once it hits
midnight you better [__] put that
thing on
yeah because that one minute yeah it's
it's a yeah so then it just it's so it's
all awful but anyways
whatever what are we going to do i know
so you let's get let's even get off that
are you so are you getting back to
being on the road and like are you
touring or what's going on
yes and how does touring work for you at
someone that's like at your stage of
like you know putting out uh eps and
putting out like yeah where are you
right now and all this
um touring's coming back stronger than
ever there's a lot of my friends are on
tour right now and they're like they're
loving it it's a lot of fun you know and
and
even here but in every other county it's
we're going full capacity shows
everything's good to go
uh i have uh my first my first show back
in uh almost two years oh [__]
we'll be opening for the jonas brothers
oh wow in milwaukee
uh kind of a kind of a high pressure
first show back but you're nervous about
it why are you nervous about it
i haven't i just haven't done it in a
long time okay
i'm very i'm anxious more than that i
think i'm just like
like the the nervous energy of of what i
know i already love
and just like experiencing again it
makes it makes me nervous but in a good
way like i'm not like scared
um and then i have a then right after
that i have a couple college shows
um and then i have a big show here that
just sold out actually at the troubadour
oh sweet in l.a that you'll you should
come to yeah i definitely will yeah
yeah bring your girl it'll be fun um
yeah man tournaments come back
and oh yeah at my level i would say
because i'm not
quite at like look i could have i could
afford a tour bus i think
but i wouldn't i would i would like
break even on a tour you know what i
mean because tour buses are like 50
grand for a month
oh jesus it's a lot um
and i would rather just be in like one
of those like nice sprinters
i'll get you with the xbox up there yeah
yeah yeah you're trying you're trying
you're making your way you're making
money yeah make some money you know yeah
you're just looking for like
are you are you constantly looking for
like um you know i guess when you're
going through your songs you're thinking
do you is there ever a part of you
that's like like are you a pretentious
artist that's what i'm saying
or is there ever a part of you that's
like i need to make a hit like like
what's the formula let me make a hit and
then the rest of my songs can be like
those great b-sides you know that people
are like
i mean where like how does your thought
process work with that what's the
business because that's
business decisions yeah the the fun part
about
that is i like i love so i love pop
music even we're talking about like
avril lavigne and room five
i love that [__] yeah yeah yeah we all
do sugar
yeah like you love that that's why it is
what it is but i like
trying to take a uh the really poppy
side
and try to bring some like weird
quirkiness into it
that's your that's just you it's who you
are yeah right i'm just a [__] weirdo
so i try to bring that into the song
um and that's the funnest part for sure
but i dude there's always a
percent we're so percentage driven on
this podcast i love it
there's a percent every whether it's 90
sometimes i just try to write it pop
banger and sometimes there's like five
percent but there always is some
got you cause cause like that's that's
what i even like when i look back to
elvis and all this stuff
that's pop music it's rock and roll but
like at that time it was that was the
poppiest music
well i mean i think it was like you know
we both love american idol so it's like
what's that thing they always say on
american idol they're always like make
it your own
like and so it's like yeah yeah so so
even if it's so even if like
you know 95 of this song is done this is
somebody's song that was already a hit
this is done like you get then somebody
comes in and they
add even a small element
that makes it their own it changes the
whole thing of it like i said
when that kid really sung that song
yellow from coldplay the way he sung it
i was like my god if he released that
right now
it would be a smash hit because it's
just the way he did it you know
so i'm saying so that's for you like you
know you're writing this thing and you
go okay what's that percentage that's
spencer yeah there and there always is
sometimes it's a
it's almost all the way like no pop
influence but yeah i mean just
you know it depends how you're feeling
in the day like if you're if you're
feeling good in this
it's a friday at 3 p.m you're gonna
write
sugar by room five you're gonna write
something that feels real good and you
can get out and go party
or whatever it is sometimes it's monday
and you're sad and it's raining
and you got to write some slow some
nirvana sad [__] you know just some
is that your thing too have you have you
written a song where you went like you
were heartbroken or
do you have that one where you just like
you know let's [__] her you know
i just i just put out a song called
shame and it's about being
it's quite literally like i'm i'm this
is probably the most honest ever been in
lyrics but it's like very honest about
like a story me being cheated on
being broken-hearted best [__] ever for
songwriting
yeah taylor swift made a whole career
out of this i think she still
i think she dates bad dudes on purpose
yeah
it makes sense i mean i i would
uh if i could if i could communicate it
like that i would too
you know one time i was in uh i don't
know if i've even told this story on the
podcast but it doesn't even matter i'm
telling you
yeah so i uh i was at mel's diner with
my boy ian edwards funny comic and we're
sitting there
after the comedy store it's late
midnight-ish and we're just sitting
there and there's like a gaggle of women
in the back of the restaurant and
they're just yip yapping and making
noise
you know and there's two like sort of
like
the two like serious men is the way i
can describe it
i mean you know what i mean like not
body guards but like
these guys are here for a reason yes
they're like russian looking
they just were like they were put they
were serious looking dudes that's all i
can describe
yeah anyways in walks two dudes they
walk towards the back
and i notice one of them and i go that
looks like to do from one direction
that's what i say to ian
i forget his name at the time so then i
like i i sneak take a picture of him and
i'm like oh it's harry's
it is harry styles it's harry styles
harry styles is walking in so then i go
oh those are harry styles
bodyguards that's my first thought you
got to be harry styles
because the guys were like you know they
were looking around yeah man it's the
way they were
you know and then so then we start
talking
with these guys because they already
assess we're not a threat
right so we're having a conversation
about the yeah yeah we're bodyguards but
they don't say anything
right okay so then we're just sitting
here kind of chilling and then like
a ruckus happens at the table okay
harry styles bangs the the thing and
then you hear hey we don't do that you
know
they're having a fight and it's like
okay we're like what the hell is going
on over there
then the girls get up and they start
some of them start walking to the
bathroom then the bodyguards get up and
go with them
because it was taylor swift so taylor
swift and harry styles were having a
fight
they were having a mel's diner they were
having a public fight in mel's diner
with their friends
and i was like and i was like oh [__] it
was like it's going down
you know what i mean but whatever and i
just thought to myself damn sucks for
them because then some idiot's going to
talk about it on a podcast
that's me right right but you know but
it was just like one of these things
where i was just like
you know it was like i was like man and
now i can see her making a song you know
i was like i'm out at mills at night you
know i mean she really did make a song
about him yeah but i get it i mean they
have like they probably had this
volatile relationship so it's like but
an art and art this song you wrote isn't
about your current girlfriend well it
sucks because i met right
the thing that sucks is i'm in love and
that sucks for songwriting oh okay well
sometimes
sometimes it doesn't i've written so
many love songs
okay i can still write them though
that's that's how i feel i still do
write them
but i is a very lovely uh girlfriend
yeah she's
she's amazing um she's actually in
budapest shooting a movie right now oh
wow
i'm gonna go visit in two weeks never
been going to budapest
yeah i know nothing about it i know that
it's in hungary i've made
[__] so many hungry jokes and
that's all well that's great so yeah
yeah so i guess like
you know people i don't know why people
like the negative people like to hear
somebody
going through something and coming out
of it they do that they can relate to
that
i mean because that's like what most
relationships are unless you're
40 plus i think you know like and even
then and even then
i was going to say even then even then
because i'm 40 plus and i'm like you
know
i've been on a roller coaster with my
chick for four years now
and now we're finally here it was like
so i don't know about you but like for
the pandemic it really solidified like
okay this is it
she's she we we if you could survive
a pandemic in california the way it was
here with the shutdown
and the yeah and the coordinating thing
yeah all the
the ups and downs of like trying to
figure out i moved
you know in the process because we she
hated my old place you make it or break
it we had some friends that definitely
like yes that broke up because they're
just like
this is [__] this is a lot even that
lived together
because they had jobs and they would
come home at night and that would be
great to have
three four hours at night but when you
got 20 24 hours
you like i don't really like you like
that i don't like it 24 hours as much
yeah
that's what i always say i started to
figure out the reason why people have
jobs and stuff is they're just like
you know they're just like oh yeah
because at 8 00 a.m and you're waking up
oh 24 hours
yeah and then at noon you're like this
[__] is still here yeah
it's a lot people are i'm sure people
like reevaluating why they had kids
because
you know what i mean like all that stuff
it's like we already went through like
you know the first four years of this
five years of this kid's life we were
every single day
i need a break you know that's what
school is for they didn't go off an
adventure and then they was like that
got taken away it was like
this was a hard yeah year for people
dean do you know that comedian sherry um
god what is her last name shepard yeah
sharer shepherd yes i do know sherry
shepard actually uh
why'd you answer like that well because
it's like it's complicated because
i was actually the best man at her
wedding
oh that she's not in anymore right and
that's why it's complicated
um well i saw her two nights ago right
and she had a bit about
her her son during during the pandemic
and he's
he's 16 and i was like that makes sense
like
that would be oh for both of them that
would be bad i was just thinking about
that too like forget about like young
kids
yeah what about like the people going
they're they're in their rebellious
teenage
stage of like 14 to 16 and they're at
home
all year oh that must have been a
nightmare i mean there is still for you
i think your parents
there was that yeah it was definitely
she painted a a
a bleak picture the bleak descriptive
picture
funny though um but yeah i couldn't
imagine like
she said like she saw him she saw his
voice drop in
puberty because she's around him yeah
yeah yeah a year she's witnessing it
yeah
crazy well i mean how was it in your
relationship like
did you guys get closer yeah got closer
i
definitely had our like little like
tiffs and stuff and
but you were already living together yep
yep never we never really questioned
uh um we got a cat oh wow
i wanted to get a dog i wish i would
have i should have just done it
you shouldn't get home you gotta
yeah she's mad for a couple days but
then it's fine because the dog's cute as
hell
yeah yeah that would have happened yeah
i i i
used to hate cats like a lot like i just
wasn't i just thought they were all
yeah um until i met her old cat and uh
her old cat oh sorry r.i.p yeah r.i.p
all right p owen we love you i want to
sign a cry
yeah um but i just like love how they
take care of themselves
i mean i don't have to do anything
except feed this cat twice a day so
you're a cat over dog
oh man
[Laughter]
the age-old argument i'm dog over cat if
i can go home to ohio and see my family
and all i don't take care of the dog i
just get to like hug the dog and stuff
oh you're wondering i love it i love it
so then then you're a cat over dog
don't don't make me say it yeah you have
to say it because
yeah that's what it is you're because
you don't want to have to deal with like
like if i had a dog too it'd be like
they can never come in here i don't want
to come home and my wires are all messed
up and
yeah yeah or like you or like your dog
like gets electrocuted from
yeah peeing on the thinking of some [__]
like that i'd be so furious
i think that just shows my maturity
levels i i just pick cat over dog
because i don't want to take care of
something more
yeah i know but i think that's a fair
yeah i don't want to like i don't want
to be a bad owner i don't want to like
not take care of the dog and then it's
neglected so
yeah i totally think that's fair i'll
get one someday for sure
i love dogs i'm gonna have a house full
of pets
that's three starring me
what's up guys let's talk some more
about green chef uh if listen
cooking at home is a great you know
cathartic
relaxing stress-free really helps you
meditate and cooking for yourself you
feel like you've achieved something
and green chef is going to help you with
that you know they have everything you
need from
all different types of meal plans that
you're looking for whatever your diet is
making leading a healthier lifestyle
easier for you with green chef
everything is hand-picked
featuring organic vegetables
high-quality
proteins delivered pre-measured and the
pre-measuring part is
super great because like when you go to
the market you know
you're trying to cook a recipe you don't
know and it calls for onions you're not
necessarily going to buy one onion so
you end up buying like three onions you
buy like too much meat
and then you have the food sitting there
or you overcook this is like
pre-measured just for you
so and portion control is a great thing
for being healthy
so like i say everything's hand-picked
and prepared and it's insulated in the
packaging green chef is the most
sustainable meal kit
offsetting 100 of its direct carbon
emissions
and plastic packaging in every box so
they're trying to help
you and they're trying to help the
environment so you can feel great about
what you're eating
and how it gets to your table
look i love cooking like i said
throughout the pandemic i was cooking
and green chef is the exactly kind of
service that i highly recommend for all
the reasons i've already said so look
guys go to greenchef.comgriffin100 and
use code griffin100 to get 100
off including free shipping that's green
chef dot com
slash griffin 100 and use code griffin
100 to get 100
off including free shipping green chef
the number one meal kit
for eating hey what's up guys
one of my favorite sponsors better help
i love better help you know i do real
world advice from a grown ass
man so i'm all about talking and and
getting some help but i'm not a
professional therapist and so betterhelp
can offer you that
what you need you know because a lot of
things interfere with our happiness
you know stuff still going on with the
pandemic it's been a rough
almost two years now so if you have some
issues and you need some help
really like working through them
pinpointing the causes to try to help
you with some coping mechanisms i highly
recommend therapy and better help is an
easy
comfortable way to do that you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video
or phone sessions all without having to
sit in that uncomfortable office
there's a lot of things like i said
you're talking about depression stress
anxiety relationships you just name it
you know you think that talking with the
therapist might not help
i guarantee you that it will it doesn't
solve your problems but what to do is
like i said it helps you pinpoint the
causes and it really helps
giving you some coping mechanisms and i
personally for me personally it was
about boundary issues and it really
helped me work through a lot of things
and i'm still working on it so
and this is with a licensed professional
counselor and specializes in
all of these types of things anger
family conflicts you name it
so i highly recommend better help
uh you know you can start communicating
with under under 48 hours and you're
ready to go
and again it's just connecting a safe
private online environment and it's
super convenient i highly recommend it
listeners check it out i want you to
start living a happier life today
as the listener of riffling with griffin
you'll get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com griffin that's
h-e-l-p-better
help dot com slash griffin join over one
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health
that's betterhelp help dot com slash
griffin for
ten percent off your first month
let's get to making our lives better
let's get back to the show cool
can keep going i just want to make sure
we're at where we're at um
so what did you like like
what were you were you watching anything
like like what are you watching like
what are you like you know i was like
you're like i always feel like musicians
and artists are like very
you know like it's like like it was
asking earlier
are you pretentious about music and you
may think that you're not but i probably
think that you are
prob probably you know what i mean like
yeah in a sense of like you know
being a bit of a snob just not you are
you snobby i
eat drink and breathe it's like right
right so you you it's it's almost like
you it's like you know as an actor when
i'm watching a movie or something
if i if it doesn't grab me i find myself
counting shots setups i find myself
counting setups when i'm looking at a
thing oh true so i'm looking at it and
i'm going like this oh that's probably a
tough day you know yeah you know
all the cameras on that guy okay that's
one setup oh it's a wide shot that's two
setups oh
the camera's another guy three setups
ooh they did a weird angle that's four
setups i wonder how long it took to make
yeah so now i'm thinking about that kind
of stuff and
you know but do you get excited about it
are you like like cause because my
girlfriend's
obviously an actor and i'm and i'm like
how did like how did they do this like
we're watching taken to and i was like
how did they
do this you know this like card
jump thing like with the camera there
and she explained exactly how they did
it
and that like excited me you know what i
got excited like that
when i was watching 1917. oh that's a
good ass like i was in the theater with
a buddy of mine rick glassman actually
you're glad
you love shout outs shout out to rick
he's funny yeah so
so uh we were in this movie together and
it just turned into a thing where
it was like how'd they do that you know
that's what it was the whole movie yeah
because it was like
because i didn't know about i didn't
know nothing about it yeah so i'm
watching the scene that opens up and i'm
like
you know they haven't cut yet you know
yeah i was just like
it is it was like 10 minutes 10 minutes
and i was like
oh [__] damn they're not cutting and
then rick's like i went out and did that
and then every time we thought
every time we thought like there was
like a wipe of the screen we would
notice and i'd be like they cut right
here that's that's kind of yeah it's
like by the wall
yeah yeah i was like that's a cut that's
okay you know so then it became like an
exciting and like
to count those kinds it was like a 14
minute like one shot though it's crazy
it's crazy that first one where he's
walking through the sh oh my god or how
about the one where like where they were
at when he was at the bridge
yeah and it was like i was like how did
they do that so that's when i get
excited
but there are other times where i'm just
like uh it's not i'm not excited because
i'm just kind of like well this is
terrible
yeah so but what i'm saying is like so
what like what have you been watching
like what's your what's your jam
you know like we all have guilty
pleasures what's your guilty pleasure
what's the you know side rick glassman
uh panel um
rick glassman and i have been been dming
for the last like four years about
playing basketball together
and then we haven't dm the last like
year and then so now when i we see each
other at mendocino farms
we've never like met in person so we'll
like know that you know that thing you
do where you're like no
no and like they might know you and
you're like you made me like nod you
like look at them
we've been doing that so rick next time
i'll say hey to you um
what i'm watching you know what's the
funny thing right now
i should do something i should do
something that rick glassman
that rick glassman does to me all the
time
what does he do he calls me during his
podcast
you know who i like that yeah he he
calls me all the time during his podcast
so i'm gonna you know what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna do the same thing to him
what are the chances rick glassman has
no idea what i'm talking about well
we're gonna we're gonna find out right
now guess what are the odds
yeah there we go i hope he answers he
probably won't answer
then i have to cut this part out or i'll
keep this part in as an example of like
of how you should answer your phone and
how you should answer your phone if
you're a real friend or if you're right
kidding sometimes you just gotta like
you just run on the treadmill and you
gotta you gotta let it go to
you're gonna let it go oh of course he's
not gonna answer this bastard
but there it is right there rick
glassman is
rick glassman not answering yeah there
it is right there
not answering rick glassman unavailable
right there right on live on riffing
with griffin rick glassman unavailable
anyways um what am i watching
i know what are you watching well
i'm so not pretentious when it comes to
film i like i like that kind of stuff
too but
man i have some weird comfort shows oh
don't don't be ashamed
tell me about it because i can tell you
mine first to make sure that you know
that you shouldn't be ashamed
loved vampire diaries that was my job
yeah
but yeah like i went through all the i
loved vampire diaries and then i loved
originals
and then i loved the new one i forgot
the name of it legacies legacy that look
at your piece of [__]
he's right there with me so i love i
love because i'm a i'm
i love vampire genre anyway yeah i i i
love reading vampire books
so i've read a lot of them even the
corny ones i read twilight series i read
the vampire academy
oh this is perfect is that rick this is
rick
wait let me see if he hello hello
yo man are you on something live
yep i'm on i'm on my i'm doing my
podcast right now and my guest spencer
sutherland we were busy talking about
you
um yeah i heard when i answered i heard
me let me see if we could hear them i'm
like oh
yeah because you do this you do wait you
do this to me all the time
yeah but never live i always ask you do
you mind after
no you always do it live no no i don't
do live podcasts i'm kind of a real
podcast no no i'm saying when you do
i'm not saying you're doing it like when
you're recording live you've called me a
couple times when you've been recording
the podcast
oh yeah but aren't you guys live no i'm
not it's not live we're just sitting
here right now we're just sitting here
he can hear you
yeah spencer can't hear you right now uh
yeah i'm at home and um
also i don't really care but uh as long
as i'm not naked
i'm at home uh at my parents house and i
just i just had um
them ship me a helix mattress and i just
put in my room it's unbelievable go to
helixsleep.com
oh my gosh we're up to 200 guys
you are you you are the worst you know
that dad
we're on eric's podcast oh he's on the
phone i was gonna have to tell you about
the mattress
tell eric how comfortable that man eric
that mattress is
really nice
yeah oh jesus christ dude i love this
panel the podcast yeah yeah yeah you
well i have to go like this right now so
people so the camera you're
you're facing the camera but your your
sound is coming in strong even though we
don't necessarily see you
but there's but there's spencer right
there
rick say marshall carpet
that's right marshall carpet i gotta
tell you
rick i have to tell you that i saw you
like five years ago stand up uh we we've
dm'd about playing basketball together
then i haven't talked to you in a couple
of years and then now i see you at mendo
sometimes and it's like going to know
him but like i don't know
know him and i'm like i remember i do
remember i was talking about basketball
you were going to help out i was filming
this uh
this video yes i think it was december
or november of like 2018.
yeah yeah yeah we haven't talked in a
while so hey i know you see me we're at
mendocito farms
i said i see it mendo sometimes and and
you know that thing where you know you
know
i can't hear now you can't hear oh now
you can't hear well
what happened no i could hear now it
broke up for a minute oh sorry sorry
sorry
i was messing with the cord i was just
telling you that that i see you at mendo
sometimes
you know that thing where you like kind
of know someone but you don't like know
them know them and you're like
yeah i feel that way about eric okay
ladies and gentlemen
that's helixsleep.com griffin slash
griffin
hey eric what what episode what week
does this episode come out it's gonna be
like
not this week but next week well then
check out last week's episode of take
your shoes off with eric griffin uh our
episode comes out tomorrow
oh great there you go that's perfect all
right and that's uh
spence if you ever see me uh uh you
could uh
you could not now now work together yeah
i think so i think it's time to finally
get a hello
look at look how i'm spreading spreading
you love this all right well thanks rick
thanks for being on roofing with griffin
this will be
what count this as your episode then it
won't air
hey i would love i don't have this setup
you should have seen this setup i just
for real i opened the mattress in the
living room it's a king mattress we
moved
the entire living room apart i brought
lights we both have the same sponsor
helix sleep
he's gonna drop the tag again yeah
anyway
i'll let you guys go but all jokes aside
that's helixly.com
griffin
bye rick that's so
funny man oh man i can't break glass i
wish i would have
like like there's just so many weight
like i'm because i'm doing it by myself
it's hard to like you know but i easily
could have like
had the video want to but it's like
right right that i need my i need wigs
here wigs isn't here today guys
uh but anyways and that's so funny a
good old a good old uh rick glassman
you know yeah a little like it's like a
radio call-in yeah that was kind of yeah
i like those kind of radio shows i miss
those the morning zoo yeah it was like
i got my buddy from high school on right
now yeah tommy what's going on
but tommy and whatever the names are
hey that you know what's funny you talk
about as we talk about radio right now
it's it's um
that isn't it funny how that's not
necessarily the goal anymore
like it's like like like like was there
a time that you would like wanted to
hear yourself on
on on 102.7 kiss yeah did you know what
i mean yeah did you want to hear like
now coming up next spencer
sutherland with sweater is that like
still still kind of
yeah i still kind of i mean right
like that's the thing about radio that
it has like totally been overshadowed by
streaming but that's the thing that'll
never go away is that like
oh who is it oh god it's rick again oh
rick's just trolling facetime they don't
hear that the thing was ringing but uh
rick was calling
the facetime hey so so my mom oh jesus
rick
[Laughter]
look i got to tell you a story though
it's hysterical
is that rick's dad this is rick's dad is
here everybody i don't know i want to
see if i can
zoom in on this right now just go ahead
we're listening all right so
my wife was talking to you to tell you
how wonderful
the helix sleep.com tyso masters
is slash griffin and then
at the end he goes he's really a
professional
basketball no i hate i'll tell you
something you grow up with funny parents
and then you realize they're not
professionals
[__] me she well they don't uh she
basically
she my neighbor my neighbor came over to
help me move the metrics with galahad
smashers.com
tyso upstairs and then we could call him
to tell him he would think that's so
cool that we just got um
uh griffin on the phone and my dad goes
he doesn't know who
eric griffin is and my mom says but
isn't he a professional basketball
player
oh so that what what a disappointment
that it's not blake griffin
now my mom said don't call him i don't
want him to think i don't know him i
just thought it was a basketball player
i know who you are and i love you
do you
[Laughter]
know the other guy i just thought it was
the basketball guy
all right i just thought that was funny
that you wanted it
oh my god griffin baby all day long
now i have to put them in the
description as they're on the podcast
yeah
yeah yeah well if you want to get views
i advise you put him in the thumbnail
oh god all right rick felixsleep.com
have a good one bye
[Laughter]
he put his parents up to a bit yeah yeah
two that that's rick that's right
glassman in a nutshell
i wouldn't i would not be surprised if
he called back a third time yeah i'll go
for sure
yeah like probably more of a chance that
he will yeah what's the over under right
now
uh a chat that you know yeah if you're
in the chat right now
you know watching it you know what do
you think it's like because like because
i'm going to do a
what do you call it a um a premiere of
this so we'll know
is rick going to call back again let's
do the over under right there but
anyways
yeah i don't even remember what we were
talking about because we got sidetracked
by the glassman family i forget to
ah it doesn't even matter oh we were
talking about what shows you like to
watch you know what's your guilty
pleasure
uh i i don't know why i think it's
because i grew up with this in the
background but i love
king of queens oh you like those kind of
i love everybody loves raymond they're
very
comfortable and like yes yes nothing
serious ever happens
just have them on in the background
sometimes you just like watch and i get
i get lost on that too like i like those
too like i like big bang theory like
that
yeah like every time i'm on a plane they
always have big bang theory and i love
let me just watch these and you just go
oh i get it this was really a funny show
also on a plane you're not really trying
to like dig into like what's eating
gilbert great
like something like real serious i've
done it before and you get off the
flight feeling weird yeah i hate being
on a flight watching like a really
serious or
sad thing and i'm i'm sitting there
crying because i'm emotional like that i
will start crying
yeah i watch a movie like i even i just
saw a black widow and i cried at the end
of it really you know because it was
it was well done yeah that is a
fantastic movie i highly recommend it
florence is in that movie right she was
so good
she's uh i think she's gonna be the i
mean she is but she's gonna be like the
next
like the biggest star in the world yeah
yeah well now that because i think
they're gonna
i think they're gonna like have her take
over for scarlett johansson it's like
you know because she's the sisters and i
think that
moving forward you've got to honor her
in a marvel movie she's going to be like
that person you know then they'll have
like
her own movie or whatever but you know
and just real quick because i've talked
about this movie already but i want to
say again
one of the things i really enjoyed about
this movie was it wasn't like one of
these
action movies that has like here's a few
some female characters
this was literally a female action movie
like
that's cool it was it was about them and
what they went through and their story
and i was like oh
it's that good it was great i was like
oh this is this is a kind of you know it
didn't matter
it really didn't matter but there is a
difference when you have like a movie
that has like oh here's a side character
as opposed to like this is the character
like that's clear they're just putting
in a female to have a female in
or whatever it is whatever that thing is
yeah yeah yeah there's that feminist
equation uh
uh i was dating a feminist once and she
said there's a there's this movie
equation thing where you go it's like
it's like is there is there a woman in
the movie
yeah okay and she has to be talking to
another woman
in the movie not about a man
wow okay so that and so then i went whoa
there's
come on there's plenty of movies like
that and then i started watching movies
and i started to think about that and i
was like
oh [__]
i forgot with this guy when i was like
oh man you start thinking about your
movies like what now she was talking
oh no that's about that guy oh yeah it
was like i was like oh no
so that's like some sort of i forgot
what that thing of that equation is
called but it's like this feminist
equation it's like it's not a good movie
for women unless
this is happening you know what i mean
so i don't know tell me if this is a
guilty pleasure no
i don't know if it is any movie with
either
nicholas cage liam neeson oh yes of
course
i am obsessed with those two dudes yes
what what am i
uh i don't know it might even been rick
saying this to me
but it's like someone was saying this to
me that like the reason why we like
like those type of movies is because
it's a bunch of dads
doing stuff that they can't do they
shouldn't yeah they shouldn't be like
kicking all these dudes asses and
croatia and that's been the thing
since you know bruce willis was the
first
one to do that bruce willis was the
first one who was like oh here's a
regular dude
being adventurous and we and we admired
him for it his hair sucks
he's not really in shape yeah he's just
he's just a dude
making [__] happen right not like he's
not like
it wasn't like stallone and
schwarzenegger who were like clearly
right in shape bodybuilder type guys you
know then it became
and that's what all these are now it's
like you got liam neeson and like
yeah man you know all these like every
liam neeson movie
it you know has the same formula right
it's that somebody's [__] with his
family
and he needs he has a particular set of
skills
and he needs to go in and take care of
business that's everything recent movie
and he
and they keep making them because we
keep going to watch them and also the
funniest part about these are
he's in usually like like sometimes just
like iowa or like some random state
yet he doesn't give a [__] about his
accent he is irish every time
yeah he always talks like this yeah it's
like there's no backstory of where he's
from he just isn't him yeah yeah he
doesn't have to you know what
arnold schwarzenegger was the same way
like yeah there came a point where we
were like
i don't care that he's not american
jingle all the way ever since
or yeah of course yeah that's my
favorite that's my favorite arnold one
surprisingly oh really
wow yeah i know it's bad but like in
true lies
it was the one that we were just like
yeah who cares he's not
like we know we yeah we know what we're
getting we just love him let's just move
on from it
there's a certain level of actor that
you like mcconaughey can do that still
he just
kind of talks like this every other part
he's like not even in texas in the movie
and he could just still
talk like matthew mcconaughey yeah
there's a guy there's people that
transcend
you know yeah where they i think it's
about believability
you know and it's like you know who's
the great i think the best at that
is denzel washington oh [__] man
from his entrance scene of whatever
movie he's in
they establish who he is cop
whatever i believe that [__]
from jump i mean that's why he is
denzel yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he and
it's and he has
that ex that like oh man he is
unbelievable he has a slight new york
accent and just
[__] so you're actually getting into
acting too right yeah man you're this
guy's
let's talk about your act let's finish
with your acting stuff because sure you
just booked a show or something like
that right what did you just do
dude i don't know how but i tripped and
fell into acting and peep and i
am for some reason p
like people are giving me a chance to
act i'm just like i'm like that guy it's
like
like that meme video but that's how i
feel before you even continue to let me
just step in here
i think that um i remember my acting
teacher i had uh
uh what was her name alhante was her
last name janet alhante
west her soul she r.i.p but she was one
of those meisner
you know oh yeah i think she actually
took classes with him that's how
bored back she goes but anyway my point
is that's the acting style yeah she's
like but my point though is that
she used to work with a lot of singers
you know
she worked with a lot of singers because
there is an element
of acting in performance in singing
there's emotions that are being emoted
when you are singing
and when you wonder why when you like
watch someone and you're moved by their
performance it's not just their voice
it's like how they're singing and you
know that thing so
i'm not surprised i say that to say i'm
not surprised
that you were getting into acting that
it sort of like feel it it definitely
feels natural for sure
yeah of course um this so i did my first
my first movie um it's a netflix movie
it comes
too loud no no no i was just one of my
nervous anxious ticks oh i just
do all kinds of ears sticking out and i
was like all right go ahead sorry when i
record vocals i do this with one ear off
so
now when i have headphones on it just
feels right to do that okay gotcha sorry
yeah
i'm a wreck um uh the movie
is coming out on netflix in um i think i
can say september who cares what i can
or not
yeah nobody's watching this pocket
these four or five thousand people that
watch me they don't give a [__] about
you know they're not gonna be like
netflix guess what he's telling you
right it's so funny when like even when
i have people on my own podcast that are
just like i can't
say like i'll tell you in a couple days
but i can't say now and i'm like
no one's gonna yeah mad i think this is
e entertainment right now
uh and what's the name of your podcast
by the way because you said it oh yeah
when's lunch
when's lunch and i've been on it yeah
eric's been on it it's a great episode
yeah
um but go on now so you're so the movie
what's the name of the movie it's called
afterlife of the party
and uh it's it's you know it's along
that like
that netflix movie formula um
it yeah it's like you did it i mean you
know are you playing a singer in it or
are you like
yes uh and i got to do a bunch of
original music for the movie oh that's
great which was actually
you know the coolest part because yeah
you know for all reasons
but they own those songs now right it's
not like you could put those songs on
uh like the soundtrack for them they own
most of them yeah yeah that sucks
but they're for the character so they're
not really something i would put out
oh i would like oh i get what you're
saying rush to put out it's the
character is like me
very much but it's a little it's not you
it's not you it's a little poppier yeah
it's not yet yeah i totally get it so
that was a blast i got to go to south
africa in the heart of the pandemic
oh wow and shoot a whole movie and we
were quarantined on a wine farm
and i don't know if you know this but in
south africa
a glass of wine is like 80 cents because
of the currency exchange
jesus so we're on this five star winery
vineyard not winery jesus and a bottle
of mine was like two dollars
but it should be like you know 80. 80
bucks yeah for real
yeah so i was just so that was great and
then i booked a show that i just shot a
couple months ago in hawaii
uh i know what you did last summer it's
not the it's like it's a
it's from the like the 90s horror films
yeah yeah freddie prince jr yeah yeah
but it's an all new story all new cast
uh my girlfriend's elite of it
oh wow yeah man this is so crazy because
she had she had are you playing her
boyfriend in it
no well they should have done that a
little bit like come on guys let's do
this love scene for real
well so she books it right then i get
the audition
uh and she's the lead of it and i'm like
oh i got this audition you can tell the
show when i was like to hire me and
she's like
it doesn't work like she's like no she
was she was playing she was like no
yeah you're gonna get this on your own
and i was like dude come on like
come on and she's like oh man
oh man she's like no you can't you you
could do this on your own
i did it on my own uh-huh thank god i
was like don't you
secretly she was like she probably told
her yeah she's like texting him by her
legs she's like hey you should really
hire him he's really struggling right
now
he's going through a [__] but don't
let him know that i told him i don't
want to know
she's like your girlfriend yeah um found
out
we are dating and there may or may not
be a scene
okay but okay well let me ask you this
then so let's say okay you're on this
show with her
but let's say your character on the show
is not dating her but there's another
hunky guy that's dating her
oh how is that how are you about that
eric we've been dating for six years
i've heard every
what am i saying kissing every guy yeah
yeah you know what i mean like
i just thought it's funny i just thought
about i was like what am i talking about
she's already been
skimpy outfits with like yeah you know
she's
she's a a beautiful girl so like
obviously she's
it books a lot of beautiful girl parts
and little girls have to do beautiful
girl things a lot of the guys
yeah a lot of the guys that she kisses
in movies and like whatever and like we
become
super good friends yeah yeah yeah yeah
it comes with just well you seem to be a
kind of guy that's really secure with
himself
that's what it comes from and yeah even
at the beginning a little bit it was
probably a little uncomfortable but then
after a while i was like dude
i'm i'm with her right like it's a movie
it's fine
it's it's you know it's not like
literally
doesn't faze me at all and i'm lucky
because i have a lot of friends who are
fazed by that
of course yeah and i'm like they always
come to me they're like what do i do
like
they they're rehearsing and i'm like
yeah let it go
you gotta go smoke a joint or something
like yeah yeah you know what and my
thing is like
i'm not saying you can't feel yeah you
know
feel but that's yo [__] yeah for sure
it's yours it's your insecurity
you know what i mean that's you so you
should be like i gotta go
and i'm gonna go deal with this and i'll
be back also the real thing
is if your girl's going to cheat on you
she's going to cheat on you
yeah it's hard to be like on it like
you you think you think she's that lazy
it's only going to be on the job
yeah yeah you know what i mean yeah so
it's like yeah for real
it's like that's yeah yeah yeah like i
had and i'm dying like
i was first i was dating rachel so i'm
on them dying up here and there's this
scene where i'm in bed with these two
naked chicks
you know what i mean i'll never forget
the day i i i
i drove i went to her place to like say
hey i just got finished working and
she's like what'd you do today and i was
like
you wouldn't really want to know about
it then she got so mad
and she even like texted me this like
she was furious like if you're gonna be
doing those kind of
things we have to break up she just was
like so in her feelings about it but the
next day she was like just can you
please ignore
what i said yeah just like you know i
just you know and but i get it
yeah the first time we were fresh we
were new it's like you know you know i
mean
like i have to i can respect
somebody's feelings but it's like what
i'm saying to people that feel that way
that's a you problem yeah and so
don't make it uh don't make it to other
people because it's like i'm living my
dream
yeah i'm following my dream i'm doing my
thing you know so it's like you have to
like you know
there are certain actors i hear you hear
them say like they'll be like
i won't kiss anyone else you know
because you know and i think that i
guess i go like you're just a
you you're just not a professional actor
it's just it's so silly
you're just not me you're just not
professional so keep that [__] to
yourself i don't care that you wanna you
know what i mean
yeah it's it's a hundred percent uh uh
just being confident in your
relationship and you're
in yourself mostly you're right it's a
you think it's a youth for
sure because if it's if it's gonna
happen
it's gonna happen yeah it happened
yeah yeah yeah right if you're thinking
it's gonna happen it probably already
happened
oh man oh [__] i gotta
you know what we're gonna wind it down
here
i just remember that my parents are
gonna be in the area oh fun
well it is and it isn't he's going to
grab a dinner or something yeah it's
something like that but
they're going to be in the area pretty
soon here but listen man this is uh
spencer sutherland uh you can find him
i'll have all this information below in
the description
yeah and uh i appreciate you coming by
we've been talking about this for a
while i already did your podcast you
know you know i'm a fan
i'm always looking at your reel now on
reels to see like okay which one can i
do do a duet with
dude i just i always i very much
appreciate how good of a friend you've
been and just
um yeah you've always been supportive
but yeah from
you know over the last few years and i
appreciate that you know once
i want us all to win yeah i mean i feel
the same way you know i mean it's just
it's like and what i appreciate is like
you know um
at all stages all ages it you know
the struggle is real yeah and it's
similar yep you know so then it's like
you know you commiserate with
you know a fellow artist yeah and it's
cool
it's cool to see when good things happen
to good people i know
for all of us yeah and well good things
are coming for this guy so make sure you
look for him on net netflix looking for
him on uh
amazon amazon for the know what you do
that yeah amazon and netflix um
an album is coming out right you have
like yep i have a new single coming out
um july 30th probably around when this
is dropping
it's called uh it's called paranoia
paranoia so check out paranoia
yeah man and uh it's gonna be a good
second half of the year it's gonna be
fun this is great man and i really
appreciate you coming over and coming on
and you know
everybody make sure you check me out on
american gaming
and uh subscribe share and make sure you
go follow spencer and all his stuff and
check it out if you're into
into that type of music and whatnot and
even just even if you're not you might
like it yeah exactly you might like it i
mean he's
such a he's his own character man you
know he's got high-waisted genes so that
lets you know like okay i get it you
know what i mean oh this [__] guy is
guy you know so check that out and uh
this has been ripping with griffin and
thanks for watching and i will see you
next week bye
that was fun perfect that was awesome